Ich bin auf dieser Station als Anasthetik. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sie sind damit einbekommen?
Ja, natürlich.
Sobald ich gerne Ihren Daten aufnehmen, dann sprechen wir über Ihre Beschwerden.
Und wenn Sie etwas nicht bestellen, können Sie bitte mir Bescheid geben.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Werner Haas.
Könnten Sie bitte Buchstabieren.
Der Name und Vorname ist Werner, C-E-R-N-E-R.
Okay.
Und der Verwundene Name ist Haas, H-A-S.
Herr Haar.
Haa-A-S.
Mähnliche Name?
Werner ist ein männlicher Name.
Ja, genau.
Herr Haar, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, Sie sind, ich habe so unglaubliche, starke Schmerzen im unteren Rücken.
Es ist gestern Abend, hat es angefangen.
Ich habe im Garten gearbeitet und habe einen ganz schweren Blumentopf zur Seite gerückt.
Und da ist es mir so richtig reingeschossen.
Und jetzt habe ich wirklich extreme Schmerzen und die Strahlen so ins rechte Bein rein.
Das kribbelt also bis in den Fuß rein.
Und ja, jetzt kann ich mich kaum noch rühren.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, jetzt sind Sie im Garten gearbeitet.
Ja.
Und nach der Arbeit sind die Schmerzen angefangen.
Eigentlich während der Arbeit, als ich etwas Schweres hochgehoben habe.
Ja, etwas schwerer Kisten angehoben, oder?
Ja, genau. Ich habe einen schweren Blumentopf hochgehoben.
Ich dachte, ich schaffte das, aber der war wohl doch ein bisschen zu schwer.
Sie haben unteren Rücken schmerzten.
Genau, ja.
Und ich habe auch die rechte oder linke Beinen.
Ja, sagt die ins rechte Bein strahlen, der ganz stark aus, bis in die Zehen rein.
Bis in die Zehen, okay.
Haben Sie Taubheitsgefühl oder Lähmung bei Ihnen?
Ein bisschen Taub fühlt sich die Außenseite vom Bein an.
Okay.
Und fühlen Sie sich in Bein kräfteschwecken, oder?
Kräfte verloren?
Das merke ich eigentlich nicht. Ich merke so, dass es halt kribbelt.
Oder kribbeln, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch etwas beschwerden?
Nee, aber das reicht mir völlig. Die Schmerzen sind nämlich wirklich heftig.
Ja.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerztekeler von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leichte, 10 leichtecken Schmerzen entschieblich?
Wie merken Sie?
Die sind bestimmt bei 8.
Ich habe richtig heftige Schmerzen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen laageabhängig oder bei Bewegung abhängig?
Ja, ich kann mich ja kaum rühren.
Und ich habe auch nachts nicht geschlafen, weil das alles wie ich wusste,
nicht, wie ich liegen soll.
Und wenn ich versuche, die Lage zu ändern, das geht überhaupt nicht.
Also ich bin richtig geplagt im Augenblick.
Okay.
Jetzt hör ich nichts mehr.
Ihr Mikro ist aus.
Ja, ich schuldige mich, ich mache das.
Ne, ne, dein Mikro ist aus.
Ne, ne, ich mach das.
Ja, ja, ja.
Haben Sie die anderen Körperteile Schmerzen?
Nee, sonst habe ich nicht.
Also wenn ich jetzt davon absehe, dass es eben so kribbelt,
wir sind fein rein, aber sonst, nee, woanders tut es nicht weh.
Herr Herr, Entschuldigung, ich würde gerne Ihre Daten nochmal etwas
Frage stellen.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 49, ich werde jetzt im April 50.
49.
Wann sind Sie jenei geboren?
Am 19.04.72.
72.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 181.
Wie groß?
Okay.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
91 Kilo wirklich.
91 Kilo.
Okay.
Herr Haft, ich würde gerne über Ihre Wege des Phanomenes
Frage stellen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht.
Steffrost oder Übelkohl?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Vor Schwarz vor den Augen?
Oder sind Sie schwindelig?
Nein, nein, nee.
Vielleicht in dem Augenblick, als es so reingeschossen ist,
da ist mir vielleicht kurz schummerecht geworden,
aber jetzt habe ich das nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
am Tag, nur so aus Genuss. Okay und Trinidad? Ja, Glas Wein am Tag, gar nicht mir wohl.
Nehmen Sie bitte die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine reine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie mit Druck und Erfahrung? Meine Jugend habe ich schon mal einen
Joint geraucht, ja, so ein bisschen Marihuana habe ich schon probiert, aber die Zeit
ist lange vorbei. Okay, aus Jugendweite. Okay und ich würde gerne über Ihre soziale
Routine sehr fragig stellen und sind Sie verheiratet? Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder? Ja, ich habe zwei Söhne. Sie sind Söhne und Ihre Frau gesund?
Sie sind alle gesund, ja. Okay, was sind Sie vom Beruf? Ich bin Ingenieur.
Okay, wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie? Ja, natürlich, klar. Ja, meine Frau hat mich
jetzt auch hierher gebracht, ich hätte ja selber nicht Auto fahren können.
Okay, super. Und leben Ihre Eltern noch, Herr Hart? Meine Eltern leben noch beide, ja.
Und haben Sie Ihre alten etwas Vorerkrankungen oder chronische Erkrankungen,
erblich Beispiel? Ja, mein Vater, der hat so ein bisschen Hüftprobleme und bei meiner Mutter hat
man jetzt festgestellt, dass die so eine Makula-Degeneration hat, die hat also mit den Augenprobleme,
aber sonst ist da nichts. Okay, haben Sie Geschwister? Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Jetzt würde ich gerne über Ihre Krankheitsgeschichte etwas fragig stellen und haben Sie Vorerkrankungen,
chronische Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel, gut ok. Ja, ich bin tatsächlich schon seit früher Kindheit Diabetiker,
also ein Typ 1 Diabetiker. Was nehmen Sie dagegen? Ich habe eine Insulinpumpe.
Insulin. Wie oft und wie viel? Wie regelt sich ja selber die Insulinpumpe? Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Insulinpumpe. Okay, wir haben gedacht. Und noch andere Erkrankungen haben Sie? Ja, seit ein paar
Jahren hat man festgestellt, dass der Blutruck ein bisschen hoch ist und die Blutfettwerte und ja,
das nehme ich halt ein paar Medikamente. Nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente, oder? Ja, ja.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie? Also ich nehme, ich habe einmal die Insulinpumpe, dann nehme ich Mikardis.
Mikardis. Wie viel Medikamente? Und wie oft nehmen Sie? Ja, das heißt Mikardis Plus und da steht meine ich 40
zu 12,5 drauf und eine morgens und eine abends und dann nehme ich eine Ato-Rastatin, das nehme ich abends,
das ist Ato-Rastatin 10. Nur abends nehmen Sie. Das nehme ich nur abends, ja. Und dann habe ich vor
anderthalb Jahren einen Hörsturz gehabt und da ist mir tatsächlich zurückgeblieben ein Tinnitus und
deswegen nehme ich Thibonin. Nehmen Sie Anathabian, aber vor anderthalb Jahren hatte ich den Hörsturz.
Ich kann nicht ganz gut verstehen. Sie nehmen Anathabian. Ich nehme Thibonin wegen des Tinnitus.
Seit wann nehmen Sie diese Medikamente? Ja, vor anderthalb Jahren, also 1,5 Jahren,
1,5 Jahren hatte ich den Hörsturz und da ist mir das nachgeblieben, dieser Tinnitus. Und mal stört
es mich mal weniger, das nehme ich also so ein bisschen nach Bedarf. Aber Sie noch andere
Vorurteile oder andere Medikamente nehmen Sie? Nee, mehr Medikamente nehme ich jetzt nicht.
Nein. Herr Har, sind Sie schon operiert worden? Nein. Herr Har, ich habe die wichtigste, alle wichtigste
Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen? Nein, ich denke mal, ich habe Ihnen jetzt schon
viele Fragen beantwortet, was ich jetzt natürlich wissen möchte, was Sie machen können, damit Sie mir
helfen, damit diese schrecklichen Schmerzen weggehen und dass mir das nicht wieder passiert. Möchten Sie
eine Schmerzmittel, wenn Sie möchten, kann ich Ihnen geben? Ja, das wäre vielleicht schon
ganz gut. Ich habe bisher noch nichts genommen und die Schmerzen sind ja schon sehr heftig.
Welche Medikamente haben Sie? Ich habe noch nichts genommen und deswegen wäre das gut, wenn Sie mir
jetzt etwas dagegen geben können. Ja, ja, ja. Sie haben keine Allergie, etwas Medikament,
dagegen etwas Medikamente? Ja, ich habe schon Allergie, aber nicht gegen Schmerzmittel,
sondern nur gegen ein Antibiotikum habe ich. Welche Antibiotikum habe ich? Gegen Amoxicillin habe
ich eine Allergie. Wie sieht sich die Allergie-Aktion aus? Ja, ich kriege dann so Hautauschlag.
Hautauschlag. Okay, ich gebe Ihnen jetzt eine Schmerzmittel. Ich möchte sagen,
vielleicht sind Sie in der Garten sehr stark gearbeitet, haben Sie in der Garten sehr stark gearbeitet
und Ihre Rückenbescheinung, die Schmerzmessung kommt von Rücken. Ja, das ist das
aufgrund der Analyseangaben gehe ich, Diskussprozess, aber Bandscheid und Vorfall aus.
Ah, okay. Ja, Sie können mir da etwas dagegen machen. Ja, wir machen so eine körperliche
Unterung und ich werde dann Röntgenaufnahme veranlassen. Wer kann das dann sehen? Veranlassen.
Nein, in der Röntgenaufnahme kann man das dann sehen, ob das wirklich ein Bandscheibenvorfall ist.
Ja, das ist gut. Ob man dazu Kontrast mit ist? Ja, Röntgen, Ihre Bandscheiben-Graphie,
nur Strahlen gibt oder ja nur Strahlen, keine Kontrastmittel. Wenn wir brauchen,
natürlich werde ich Ihre Körper, Ihre Bandscheiben oder Wirbelsäule, Computer-Tomografie,
vielleicht brauchen. Wenn wir brauchen, das kann man dann nachher machen. Ja, nachher. Was kann man da
dann sehen? Was kann man da dann sehen in der Computer-Tomografie? Ja, ich erwarte,
Ihre Bandscheiben nicht ganz passen, vielleicht etwas schlechter und die Nervenprobleme,
vielleicht Liegamentum oder Sehnenprobleme können wir schauen. Ach so, also man kann feststellen,
ob die Nerven irgendwie geschädigt sind oder ob an den Sehnen irgendwas ist. Ja, gut, okay. Gut.
Also, ich bin fertig. Ja, ich auch. Gut, also der Patient war es jetzt im Varschitzel. Ja,
so, okay. Die Schwester ruft Ihnen und Ihre Vitalparameter messen und körperliche Unterrichtung
vorbereiten. Ja, gut. Jetzt hat denn noch jemand Fragen dazu. Guten Abend. Hallo. Mahmoud,
bin ich eine wichtige Frage, ich denke, ich merke, dass ich ein brennend, ja. Ja, wenn ich das jetzt so
genau wüsste, ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich sind Sie eher stechend brennend als drückend.
Und nur im Bezug auf die Differenzialdiagnose ist es notfändig, Fragen zu stellen,
haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine gerötet geschwollen oder? Ja, also gerötet und geschwollen ist mein
Bein nicht, es kribbelt nur und es ist taub. Und also, ja, nach meiner eigenen Erfahrung mit
Hexenschutz würde ich mal sagen, die Schmerzen sind brennend stechend. Und die Differenzialdiagnose
im Bezug auf eine
Ja, gerne. Und ich habe auch eine Frage, haben Sie sich eingenäßt? Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
So, sollen wir weiter machen oder gibt es noch weitere Fragen? Noch eine Frage, bitte.
Können Sie Ihr Urin halten? Ich meine, müssten Sie beim Nesen oder beim Hüsten wasser lassen?
Nein, keine Probleme. Das fehlt mir noch.
Haben Sie Spitzfuß? Noch mal, bitte. Haben Sie Spitzfuß? Ein Spitzfuß. Nein, also der Fußgerät, ich habe nur dieses Gefühl, dass der Fuß halt kribbelt und dass die Schmerzen bis in die Zähnen reinziehen und bis in die Ferse.
Aber ich kann den Fuß aufsetzen, aber es tut halt wahnsinnig weh, deswegen schon ich den natürlich.
Ja, als Differenzialdiagnose können wir auch fragen, haben Sie Probleme beim wasserlassen?
Nein, aber mit dem wasserlassen hat der Patient keine Probleme.
Und treiben Sie Support?
Eine gute Frage.
Ja, außer der Gartenarbeit macht er nicht viel Sport.
Hin und wieder mal ein bisschen Fahrrad fahren, aber er arbeitet eher im Büro.
Kein Sportler.
Schöne Frage. Bin ich lange nicht gefragt worden.
Okay, viele vergessen, aber nur als Schmerzen konstant geht.
Ja, gut, wir machen weiter. Arztgespräch.
Okay, guten Tag, Frau Obersten, oder?
Ja, Frau Obersten. Ich bin heute morgens eine Patientin, einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen, wenn Sie sagen.
Ja, erzählst du mal, wer ist das denn?
Ja, der Patient heißt Werner Haar.
Der ist 49 Jahre alt und ein Meter alt, groß, 91 Jahre alt.
Der wollte wegen unteren Rücken Schmerzen, ja, die Schmerzen vergessen,
nach der Gartenarbeit, nach dem Gartenarbeit.
Vorgestern? Nein, nur gestern.
Gestern, okay.
Ja, gestern, nach der Gartenarbeit aufgetreten.
Und die Schmerzen schütteren in den beiden Beinen.
Und auch die rechten Fußstaben, die Schmerzen.
Sie strahlen beide Beine, aber bis zum rechten Fuß?
Ja, die Schmerzen, ja, gehört aber.
Und die Schmerzen würden auf einer Schmerzkala bei 8 von 10 liegen.
Oh, hat ja auch Schmerzen, ja.
Ja, deswegen gab ich den Patienten eine Schmerzmitteil.
Was haben Sie ihm gegeben?
Nichts, Stölder Anti-Romatoida, Ibuprofen, 100 mg.
Und der Patient hat gesagt, dass er beim Fuß parestensie leidet.
Und die Bekartetiefe an dem Neuse ist unauffällig.
Und an Vorrückrankungen leidet er an Diabetes Meditus-Tipp 1.
dagegen benutze er in Südenkumpen.
Und Arteriehypertony, auch Arteriehypertony leitet er seit ein, 2 Jahren,
aber ich bin nicht der, einigen Jahren, einigen Jahren diagnostiziert.
Und dagegen nehme er Neucardis plus 40, plus 12,5 mg.
2 Mal Antag, 1 Mal morgens, 1 Mal abends.
Er nimmt das Atua-Vastatin.
Noch mal bitte.
Weshalb nimmt er das Atua-Vastatin?
Ja, wegen Hyperlipidemia.
Ja, okay.
Und er leidet auch an Tinnitus, dagegen nehme er Tebonin.
Ja, seit 1,5 Jahren leidet er an.
Oh ja.
Er sei keine operiert worden.
Nicht operiert?
Noch nie operiert worden.
Er leidet an Amoxilin.
Wie kann ich sagen?
Allergie.
Ja, ja.
Er hat eine Allergie gegen Amoxicillin.
Gegen Amoxicillin, die sich durch Exantem oisere.
Exantem, genau.
Er hat sonst irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten?
Hautausflug.
Ob er sonst irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten hat?
Ja, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Okay.
Vielleicht kann ich weiter Untersuchung fragen.
Er rauft 2, 3 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Nicht besonders.
Er trinkt ein Glas Wein pro Tag.
Er probiert Mariona.
Als Jugendlicher.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er arbeitet als Enginier.
Er wohnt mit seiner Familie.
Er lebt sein Eltern.
Leben.
Und keine Geschwister.
Und Diabetes haben die aber nicht?
Nein, die haben keine Geschwister.
Und was ist jetzt Ihre Diagnose?
Aufgrund der an einem nessischen Angaben.
Ich fahre von Discus prolapse aus.
Und wo?
Lombard Discus prolapse.
Ja, Lombard Discus prolapse.
Im Lombarbereich.
Was wäre differentialdiagnostisch möglich?
Ja, aus differentialdiagnose käme auch
Muskelverschwarnung.
Kann ich sagen.
Und ja, ich habe nicht etwas Fragen gestellt.
Aber Metastasen oder...
Das wäre schlechteste Fall.
Ich könnte auch noch schlechtes Fall sein.
Ja, schlechtes Fall sein.
Was wäre noch möglich als differentialdiagnose?
Ja, osteoporos, Föntes.
Ja, und dann ne Fraktur.
Ja, und dann Fraktur.
Ja, und dann auch Fraktur.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt diagnostisch?
Ja, diagnostisch.
Wenn ich meine Verletztendiagnose bestätige,
oder ja, ich werde erst körperliche Untersuchungen.
Worauf achten Sie da besonders?
Ja, besonders Farbeveränderung,
Wärmerveränderung und Geschwollung.
Geschwollung?
Geschwollung auch erschränkte Beweglichkeit.
Ja, wie nennen wir das?
Beweglichkeit.
Ein...
Wie kann ich sagen?
Mobilität.
Ja, Mobilität.
Ja, und auch noch ganz wichtig,
worauf gucken Sie noch?
Der hat ja Kribbeln angegeben.
Ja, Kribbeln und Parasitut, Lemos,
Parapyligie kann ich auch.
Parapyligie ja nun nicht gerade,
aber überhaupt die Sensibilität von den Beinen checken, ne?
Ja, Muskelkraft, vielleicht kann ich untersuchen.
Muskelkraft, ja, und, also, ja, genau.
Und eben die Sensibilität, ob der Nervenausfälle hat.
Ja, gut.
Und ja, es gibt so ganz spezielle Zeichen,
Fachbegriffe.
Das fällt mir nicht ein.
Lasseg und Kernig.
Kernig.
Das sind die beiden für Nervendehnung.
Ja, gut.
Und ja, wo nach gucken Sie noch?
Was machen Sie palpatorisch?
Ja, palpatorisch besonders...
Arterellpusse.
Auch, ja.
Wegen fraktur, Ausschließung, vielleicht, ja, könnte sein, oder?
Wenn die Pulse ja nicht wegen der Fraktur,
das wäre ja, wenn der eine Durchmutungsstörung hat.
Dann müssen wir die Pulse tassen.
Aber warum müssen wir denn,
was müssen wir palpatorisch rausfinden?
Im Rückenbereich?
Ja, im Rückenbereich, palpatorisch, untersuche ich.
Ja.
Wo auf gucken Sie?
Drückdollar-Schmerz.
Ja, darauf holte ich raus.
Genau.
Klopfschmerz und Druckschmerz.
Ja, deswegen habe ich hier schon auf dem Tisch geklopft.
Gut, also.
Im Labor, was machen Sie da?
Ja, ich werde Brut abnehmen.
Brutbild, Seripä, Sedimentation,
besonders Chaosium, Berserwölf.
Ach so, ja.
Ja.
Gut, und was machen Sie für eine Apparative Diagnostik?
Apparativ, was machen Sie da?
Der Dimmerbrutgruppe.
Nein, ich bin jetzt schon weg vom Labor.
Dann machen wir ein Apparativ, einen weiteren Untersuchung.
Weiterer, weiterer.
Okay, ich werde einen Röntgen-Lomba heranlassen.
Genau.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Ja, ich erwarte die, wirken,
ganz schlechte Position oder...
Okay, ja.
Also praktisch den Nachweis des Discos-Polaps und was wir eben ausschließen, was können wir ausschließen über die Röntgenaufnahme?
Was können wir sicher ausschließen über die Röntgenaufnahme?
Fraktur?
Ja, genau.
Und wenn wir nicht genug sehen,
Wenn ich noch das MRT hinterherschieben.
Wenn der jetzt tatsächlich einen Bandscheibenvorfall hat, was kriegt der denn dann für eine Therapie?
Ja, so eine Möglichkeit. Die erste Medikamantischtherapie.
Was eben Sie denn erst mal überhaupt entscheidend wichtig?
Ja, die erste, die Kombination, Muskel-Relaxan.
Wenn ich nicht ganz gut behandle, gebe ich auch intramuskulär Medikamente oder intramuskulär Methode.
Ja, okay, heute so.
Wenn ja nicht gut behandelt, den Patienten, empfehle ich operativ zu der Therapie.
Was machen wir dann bei der operativen Therapie?
Ich werde eine orthopädische Konzil bestellen.
Ja, genau.
Und was würden die operativ machen, die Orthopäden?
Ich glaube Stabilisierung.
Ja, die würden die Bandscheibe rausnehmen und würden das praktisch festmachen, die beiden Wirbel, wo das klemmt.
Ja, gut.
Und jetzt habe ich doch ein paar Zusatzfragen.
Welcher Nerven ist das, der jetzt betroffen ist? Welches Dermatom?
Ne, Ischias.
Genau, der Ischias ist es, genau.
Und dann fragen die hier noch zur Differenzialdiagnose,
wenn wir tatsächlich eine Metastasierung sind, würden.
Von welchem Primarius müssten wir ausgehen?
Ja, Patient ist Männer, Männern nicht Prostata.
Prostata, oder?
Sistit, oder nicht Sistit, aber die andere Namen, Belase.
Okay, Belase wusste ich jetzt nicht, habe ich hier auch nicht angegeben.
Hier ist noch die Lunge mit angegeben.
Ja, dass die Lunge gerne in die Wirbelsäule metastasiert.
Aber Lunge und Prostata wären die Sachen, wo man dann weitergucken müsste.
Mama kaltest du noch mit den Metastasien?
Ja, nur handelt es sich ja hier um Mann, wobei auch Männer ja von einzigen Mama-Katzenungen haben, schon richtig.
Aber ja, stimmt.
Genau, das kennt man von vielen Frauen, da gibt es ja wie ich,
das Mama-Katzenum ist so häufig immer wieder die Geschichte, dass das in die Wirbelsäule geht.
Ja, genau.
Gut, das war von mir aus alles, was ich wissen wollte.
Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was bei ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt über den Patienten.
Gut, ich habe tatsächlich, warte mal, irgendeine Sache hatte ich.
Genau, da stimmt irgendwie die Angabe nicht so genau.
Patientname, glaube ich.
Was war denn das? Bitte?
Patientenname, glaube ich.
Ja, Haas, der heißt Haa, doppel A, S, wie der Haase mit zwei A, nicht Haak, genau.
Und ja, tatsächlich hast du nicht nach Allergien im Vorfeld gefragt
und hast auch nicht nach Lebenswettelunverträglichkeiten gefragt.
Ja.
Und genau, und ich glaube mit dem Hörsturz, da war auch ein Verbindungsproblem bei uns,
dass wir das nicht gut kommunizieren konnten gerade,
da haben wir uns selber nicht gut verstanden, passend zum Hörsturz.
Der hatte also vor 1,5 Jahren, 1,5 Jahre, hatte der den Hörsturz
und danach hatte er eben dann den Tänitus.
Oder seitdem hatte den Tänitus.
Okay.
Und ja, ich glaube, das war es aber auch schon.
Genau. Und also praktisch im Augenblick, als der den Blumentopf angehoben hat,
den schweren Topf, direkt bei der Gabenarbeit ist ihm das reingeschossen.
Also kann man quasi davon ausgehen, dass der in dem Augenblick,
dem die Bandscheibe rausgeflogen ist, wo er schwer gehoben hat.
Das ist ja praktisch eine Momentaufnahme, also einen Augenblick,
wenn die Schmerzen dann mit einem mal einschießen und ja, dann geht nichts mehr.
Gut. Ja, hat irgendjemand von den Kolleginnen,
Kollegen noch Hinweise, Fragen, Anmerkungen zu unserem Patienten?
Also erschöpft.
Okay.
Alles gut.
Danke.